national ID or a passport and some form
of legal identity in almost every
country is required to vote get a SIM
card or open a bank account in fact of
the 1.7 billion people in the world who
are unbanked 20% is due to not having a
legal identity
now you don't have to be an expert to
see that this times a billion is a big
problem
so it's not surprising that evidence
shows that improved birth registration
coverage goes hand-in-hand with improved
development outcomes from poverty
alleviation to better health nutrition
education economic improvement and safe
and orderly migration in 2015
world leaders came together and promised
that they would uphold human rights of
all people and leave no one behind and
efforts to end poverty hunger and reduce
inequalities but how are they gonna
uphold human rights and how do they know
if anyone is being left behind if they
do not know who they are or where they
are in the first place so what can
countries do about this now there's a
one-size-fits-all model because every
country contexts unique there are five
proven interventions that can be applied
to any system number one reduced the
distance to remove the cost three
simplify the process for remove
discrimination five increased demand
gender discrimination remains a hidden
problem because statistically there's no
difference between registration rates of
boys and girls but the discrimination
isn't against the child is against the
mother Angola was one of 35 countries
that required a father's name or to be
present in order for the child's first
to be registered so in situations where
the father is unknown unwilling or
unable to claim paternity the mothers
are legally prevented from registering
the births of their own children so to
address this Angola put a policy in
place allowing mothers to register their
children as a single parent in Tanzania
in 2012 only 13% of children had a birth
certificate so the government came up
with a new system they put registration
centers in existing infrastructure such
as community wards and in health
facilities so they brought the services
closer to the people who needed them
they removed the fee they simplified the
process
and automated it so the birth
certificate could be issued on the spot
to increase demand they rolled out a
public awareness campaign letting no
letting people know that there's a new
process and why it was important to
register the births of their children in
just a few years in the districts where
the new system was put in place 83% of
children now have birth certificates and
they're in the process of rolling this
out nationwide so what can you do
see I believe we are all united by our
humanity we are live on the same earth
we breathe the same air and while none
of us chose to be born or the situation
we were born into we do get to choose
how we live change occurs when a moment
of awareness or a moment of compassion
inspires a person to act and through our
collective action we become the most
powerful agents of change
and when the cost of inaction is
innocent children are left unprotected
unvaccinated unable to go to school
growing up to be adults who are unable
to find decent work or vote trapped in a
cycle of poverty exclusion and
invisibility it comes down to us to take
this issue out of the darkness and into
the light because it's not every day you
get the opportunity to change the world
but today you do
[Applause]
[Music]